mama party girl she just wants the day
just got cuter party girl Bianca Bryant
has stolen the show once again Vanessa
and the late Kobe Bryant's daughter made
another unexpected cameo in her older
sister Natalia's tick-tock Natalya and
her friend WNBA Rookie Sabrina Enescu
are first seen dancing to party girl by
stay solid rocky she say she's gonna
call me both I told Tommy Rock she says
she knows all call me that you say
you'll come
trying to keep a straight face the two
besties were joined towards the end by
Bianca Bella who adorably popped up
right in front of the camera and bebe
got some moves the three world is
dancing with her fists up rocking a
bright yellow sweatshirt and the cutest
smile in the end Natalia and Sabrina
couldn't help but bust up in laughter
Vanessa who shared the video on
Instagram captioned it another bebe
special Bianca was humming the song the
whole time in April Bianca first made
her tik-tok cameo debut Natalia is seen
dancing - we rock from the 2008 Slade
camp rock with her two cousins the girls
are totally slaying the routine until
Bianca slides into the video and
straight-up steals the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rocking a Lakers tee this little one has
moves for days as the Bryant family
shares precious moments together they're
still mourning the loss of Kobe and
Gianna in the months since their tragic
death fans have been sharing their
tributes for the two through social
media but this has only made the
grieving process more difficult for
Vanessa and Natalya the mama for wrote
on Instagram thanks so much for all the
love
Natalia Brian and I have unfortunately
had to block fan pages because it's been
really hard to go online and constantly
see pics of our beloved Gigi and Kobe
under every single square of our explore
pages blocking the fan pages has helped
change the algorithm we love you all but
please understand we had to do this for
our own healing and part of that healing
is honoring her late husband and
daughter by getting tattoos
Vanessa shared her new ink on her wrist
for Gianna and a tribute to Kobe on her
neck
[Music]
even though Vanessa didn't share what
the messages were it's clear they're
meaningful to her